six heures de jeu
qu'est ce qui faisait l'unanimité dans
les années 80-90 gadgets pour les
mélomanes le walkman lewis island
reconnaissait le z jalouse un peu à ces
deux modèles pas gelé même jamais eu
celui le sony gens oui le fameux son
iphone il faut le dire la musique
portable elle a commencé vraiment avec
le walkman si on écoute aujourd'hui de
la musique partout où on va avec
évidemment nos lecteurs mp3 c'est
d'abord et avant tout parce que ça
commençait avec ça il faut savoir
qu'avant le plus petit modèle qui reste
alitée ses 5000 vous rappelez l'on
enregistré avec sage en une photo cécile
b c'était gros c'était probable plus
approprié pour les journalistes radio
comme nous que pour les mélomanes mais
par les mélomanes c'est l'un des
fondateurs de sony qui justement écouter
la musique d'opéra un peu partout sur la
planète dans les avis des autres qu'il
faut que vous trouviez quelque chose de
plus portable que ça ils sont arrivés
avec le walkman 750 $ en 1979 en dollars
courants ça veut dire 475 $ aujourd'hui
et ça a été la folie ils en ont vendu
pendant toute la durée de vie 200
millions de ses walkman ya plusieurs
compagnies qui les ont imités aussi avec
leurs propres versions faut dire que ce
n'est toujours conservé le leadership en
innovation notamment avec des modèles
autorités
parce que dans le tente on évite ainsi
d'avoir retourné la cassette raison au
kek et oui et pendant une décennie plus
d'une décennie a personne qui ait pu
menacer l'hégémonie du walkman c'est
devenu un compagnon pour vous le savez
la marche la course le jim l'étude nos
maisons parce qu il nous suivait partout
et je vous vois sourire c'est
manifestement pas quand mais aussi moi
je quittais jamais la maison sans mon
voisin et pour illustrer jusqu'à quel
point ce gadget la marque et nos vies
parce que nous sommes davantage de cette
génération autour de cette table que du
ipod toute l'équipe est en studio pour
faire un petit jeu avec vous ils zabel
on va faire jouer deux chansons
marquantes vous allez tenter de savoir
qui ça conserve et ensuite on ira tous
d'une petite anecdote ça commence
maintenant
ça doit être la génération de janick
tremblay dit c'est peut-être de ma
génération mais c'est pas moi et ben là
j'ai perdu
1987 l'album some stand je pense que
visuellement je n'oublierai jamais la
cassette étiquette blanche avec des
simples lettres noires
1987 s'obstine twitter sauf à jouer dans
votre walkman oh mon dieu jusqu'à
épuisement je pense que je l' ai dû
acheter du foie la cassette
c'était de loin ce que j'ai le plus
écouté j'adore cette chanson combien
entente idyllique os mais ce que j'ai
écouté un rafale c'était bizarre
juste le petit jeu c'est le new world
les coudes ça me plonge dans une espèce
de nostalgie le repos est déprimante ce
genre de chansons qui me fait mal au
coeur et qu'on appelle à quel point j'ai
vieilli
à
ça
et tiens c'est pas moi même avions subi
mais non c'est compliqué russie et c'est
évidemment c'est sting avec portland
your dreams qui a connu la plus belle
mort pour une cassette qui est morte
dans mon cas et moi j'étais vraiment
anecdote un poster boy peuvent faire de
publicité pour ses walkman jaune qui
était en jeu levet à la ceinture sur mon
maillot léopard confectionné par ma mère
et je passais faut balayer émerger ici
parce que c'était étant je voulais
je ne peux pas faire semblant je sais
pas c'est qui ces moines
tous les tous les disques de soupe est
en panique à 7 j'ai gardé longtemps les
disques j'ai probablement encore des
cassettes que j'ose pas jeter jeu comme
ça moi je sentis d'accord donc des cas c
est vrai ça jouerait là dedans soit
macho leur a terni va vouloir me lire h
bon alors il ya un risque que deux je
vais dire etienne les notes qu on n aura
à ça c'est pendant mon grand voyage la
course autour du monde une vingtaine
d'années on était parti avec des grosses
cassettes vidéo et j'avais donc décidé
d'épargner une musique parce que mon sac
était plein de cassettes vidéo ea au
bout de trois mois de voyage j'en
pouvais plus cher en italie je me suis
acheté deux cassettes avec mon petit
walkman deux cassettes de leonard cohen
que j'écoutais pendant trois mois sans
arrêt jusqu'à mon retour à montréal
alors c'est un grand souvenir
tim est sauf pourquoi
quand je suis revenu toujours comme ça
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est un épisode
de chambre en ville
l'écouté des émissions de télé que je
transpirais sur des cassettes audio
pendant la route montréal orlando en
floride
c'est moi j'écoutais la télé dans les
oreilles déjà c'était quand elle s'est
trahi à la peau droit de faire de la
météo on vous retrouve après 16 heures